we're told that each square below
represents one hole so this big square
right over here is a hole and then this
big square over here is another hole
then they asked us which of the
following does the shaded area represent
select all that apply so let's see the
shaded area we're shaded in blue so
let's see one way to think about it is
we have one hole over here and then over
here we've divided it into tenths
there's 1 2 2 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 equal
sections and we've shaded in one of them
so we've shaded in 1/10 so this would be
one hole and 1/10 so we could say that
this is 1 and 1/10 so that's one way to
think about it but what about these
other ones well even this one has been
divided into tenths and you could view
one hole as ten tenths you see that here
where we've divided it into 10 equal
sections ten tenths and we've shaded all
ten tenths in so this hole you could
view as ten tenths 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
and then we have an 11th 10 an 11th 10th
I should say so we have if you if you
count these blue rectangles we have 11
tenths so you could also write this as
11 tenths now 1,100 no I don't think we
haven't even divided this into
hundredths and 11 hundredths would be a
little more than 1/10 and so this is
definitely way more than that so I can
check my answer and actually you don't
see it but it's happening off screen but
this is what I would go with for that
let's do let's do a couple more of these
so it says which of the following
describes the location of the point on
the number line let's see I have one and
then between 1 and 2 I've divided it
into 10 equal spaces 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 so each of these tick marks or hash
marks is going to be 1/10 so this is 1
and 0 tenths 1 in 1/10 1 and 2 tenths 1
and 3 tenths 1 in 4 tenths 1 in 5 tenths
1 in 6 tenths
7/10 1 and 8/10 so 1 and 8/10 is the
same thing as 1 point 8 1 and 8/10 so
it's that what about these other options
well one way we could think about this
is let's just count the tents each of
these hash marks is 1/10 so 0 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 it makes sense a hole is 10
tenths but let's keep going we were 10
tenths 11 1012 1013 tenths or teen
tenths 15 tenths 16 tenths 17 tenths 18
tenths so this one also applies 18
hundredths this would be between 10
hundredths and 20 hundredths which would
be the same thing as between 1/10 and
2/10 so 18 hundredths is going to be
someplace someplace around here so I
definitely will not select that one
let's try let's try a few more of these
so they say write a decimal that is
equal equal to 24 tenths all right 24
tenths so remember we could view this as
I'll just write it down we could view
this as 20 tenths 20 tenths plus 4
tenths plus 4 tenths but what is 20
tenths what is 20 tenths equal to 10
tenths is equal to a whole so 20 tenths
is going to be equal to 2 wholes so this
could be viewed as 2 plus 4 tenths or
another way to write this we could just
write 4 in the tenths place so we could
just write this as 2 point 4 24 20
tenths is are 2 holes and then you have
another 4 tenths let's do another one
100 200 s so we could rewrite this as
100 hundredths 100 hundredths plus 2
hundredths 2 hundredths now what is 100
hundredths well 100 hundredths is equal
to 1 is equal to a whole so 100
hundredths is just equal to 1 so you
could view this as 1
plus two hundredths another way to write
two hundredths is 0.02 so what's one
plus 0.02 well it's just going to be one
point zero two and you see that here you
have one and two hundredths one is the
same thing as a hundred hundredths so
this is a hundred hundredths and you
have two hundredths gives you a hundred
and two hundredths hundredths okay let's
do another one
what is thirty two tenths written as a
decimal so we just have to remind
ourselves ten tenths is equal to a whole
twenty tenths is equal to two ones
thirty tenths is equal to three ones so
this is going to be equal to three ones
and then another two tenths three ones
and another two tenths let's keep going
what is two hundred three hundred
certain as a decimal what you have to
remind ourselves at two hundred
hundredths is equal to two ones so here
this is the same thing as two ones and
three hundredths two ones in this case
right here two ones and three hundredths
let's do let's do a couple more of these
one point zero five is equal to how many
hundredths well one hole or one is equal
to 100 hundredths so this is a hundred
hundredths plus five hundredths or a
hundred and five hundredths all right
let's do another one
how can two point six zero be written in
words so I could write this as two and
six tenths two ones and six tenths I
could also think of this as two ones and
60 hundredths or I could do this as two
hundred and sixty hundredths so let's
see which of these choices so two ones
and six hundredths no no it's two ones
and 60 hundredths not six hundredths
it's six tenths right over here six
tenths or sixty hundred so I won't
select that 260 hundredths yeah that's
right because two ones is the same thing
as two hundred hundredths and then we
have another 60 hundredths right over
there so that's right 260 tenths no 260
tenths remember
ten tenths is equal to a whole so 260
tenths would be 26 would be 26 ones so
it's not that choice either so anyway I
think we've done plenty of examples
hopefully you have enjoyed that